oh
homo
je vous propose aujourd'hui de remonter
le temps et de vous arrêter à l'époque
du moyen-age une association baptisée
escalibur yvelines s'est créé il ya cinq
ans à mes côtés son président arnaud de
maizière arnaud concrètement qu'est ce
qu'on va faire aujourd'hui
avant on va s'équiper on va se mettre en
armure et on va combattre comme au xiiie
siècle
c'est pas trop lourd mais l'armure non
les gens y arriver on y va on va y
arriver
oui c'est parti à l'ope
[Musique]
alors à redon les devants la fameuse
armure allait proposer de quelle matière
a expliqué nous voilà en fait vous avez
l'armure d'un homme d'armes et xiiie
siècles dont quelqu'un de quand même
assez aisée c'est pas forcément un
chevalier ça plutôt être un piéton donc
on va voir une première couche de
textile faire bien de sauver des coûts
et par dessus on va mettre une couche de
métal de méthode alors là on à de la
maille alors je vais regarder le ja je
vais un peu soupeser ah oui
effectivement pris 15 kilos 12 et 15 kg
ha oui mais le poids total c'est autour
de 25 kg c'est bon je suis rentré dépôt
à certains endroits on va avoir des
parties métalliques solide mais c'est
surtout une armure textile parce que
l'essentiel de la défense qui est donc
bouclier cote de maille tout
l'équipement 25 kg c'est ça à peu près
rob à l'enfiler c'est parti que des
pâquis pour rien non vous tester on va
tester
ok tu as des armes dont boucliers ton ep
sur ton ep
[Musique]
dieu vient de sortir c'est bon tu as
toutes les chances
ok t'as pas beaucoup d'armure il faut
apporter avec le bouclier donc tu vas
essayer de toujours le tendre un peu
près comme ça ton était t'as pas de
protection aux mains une fois que tu as
frappé qui met en garde lorsque tu feras
petit tord le bras mais ses appuis bien
le dos droit
voilà là tu attaques voiture vient mais
tu essayes de paraître le bouclier les
breuilletois bonne chance
bonjour monsieur
donc
si j'ai bien compris comme ça
ah oui d'accord pour envoyer les
gentiment
[Musique]
résistez résistez appui
vie des gens disent les gens
[Musique]
en moins cher
très très bien ça va suffire je pense
que tu es prêt à rejoindre l'association
je suis prêt c'est vrai je vais retirer
là que de mal parce que j'ai vraiment
trop trop chaud tous les repas la
cotisation
effectivement merci beaucoup pour ce
cours d'initiation alors comment on fait
pour s'inscrire à l'association à tous
les détails sont sur le site excalibur
et blé une point fr ne vous fait pas que
la reconstitution on fait aussi des
animations dont des protections adaptées
et encore plus dangereux encore plus
dangereux c'est moins lourd peut-être au
niveau de leurs plus chauds du chiot bon
bah on va continuer à tester un petit
peu ce sport plaisir
oui
oh